Dustin is in South Carolina hi Dustin
Merry Christmas hey Dave merry Christmas
to you thanks for taking my call
sure what's up so I'm currently a
graduate student and I have already
taken out a little bit of student debt
to pay for my program but I also
recently started listening to your
podcast and so my wife and I are looking
at ways to prevent going further into
debt um and we we we do have a little
bit of money that my wife had saved up
prior to us getting together but we're
totally in it together at this point and
we're we're looking at at tapping into
that money originally she was actually
hoping to save it for a down payment on
a house after I graduate but now that
I've kind of been listening to you I
know that the house would be kind of
down down the road a little bit so we're
looking at using that money more wisely
currently what do you study um Nurse
Anesthesia so very good thing Dana
definitely yeah so when do you write
when you graduate I graduate in May of
2021 18 months and how much more is it
gonna cost you to finish it's gonna it's
gonna cost me about $30,000 more from
right now and how much is in savings
about 15,000 okay how you gonna cover
the other 15 I was planning on taking
out student loans for that okay does she
work because she does work and she makes
a decent income we live off her income
and there isn't much left over after
that okay you have any breaks you have a
summer off or anything no I don't get
any breaks unfortunately I do what I can
I do a little bit of lift driving when
and where I can but my particular
program is very involved the vast
majority of students don't work at all
so I don't really have too much
opportunity to make money myself my wife
vast majority of students have turned
twenty five thousand dollars in student
loan debt this is not an option we're
not measuring against that yeah that's
true but the yeah well I'm definitely
using the savings to finish
and I'm gonna scratch and claw and get
every nickel out of the corner of the
couch and see if I can't finish this
with no more debt what you said earlier
in the conversation I completely agree
with but dude you're gonna be making
serious Bank as soon as you pass those
boards this is a great career field
you're gonna be ding ding
now how much student loan debt you
already how much student loan debt do
you already have right now I'm at about
42,000 oh good okay not much at all
you're gonna pay that off in 20 minutes
which means you yeah as soon as you get
on well get out and get rolling but I
guess that's kind of what leads me to my
question for you is I also very recently
found out that in order to invest in a
Roth IRA there's actually a cap on your
household income in order to be able to
invest directly in that and so my
question was being that when I graduate
I'm under the impression that about 2200
thousand dollars jointly for a household
household income and I I would expect
our joint income to be above that once I
graduate and start work which prepare
income would be above that yeah exactly
hopefully maybe and so it in that case
would would it be smart to take that
savings and put it in Iraq while we
still can so to speak no because in
effect what you've done is you borrowed
student loan money to put into a row
right true and I wouldn't do that no
I'll never do that
now here's the other thing number one
you likely will be working with an
organization as a 401k and you can load
that thing full so and it might even be
a Roth 401k so you've got you've got
other options to save in addition to
that yes you are you cannot do a Roth
IRA when you're baked over 200,000 but
you can do a Roth IRA when you make over
200,000 by using what's called the
backdoor Roth IRA technique I do it
every year my wife does it every year
and all that is is you open an after-tax
traditional after-tax traditional IRA in
30 seconds later roll it into a Roth and
there is no income limit on that and so
it's just an extra step to get you into
a Roth but even if you couldn't do that
we would never tell you to borrow
student loan money to fund a Roth and
borrowing extra to pay for your school
because you used your savings for a Roth
it has the exact same effect and no I
would never do that
some men I'm so proud of you you've got
a great career field you're gonna make a
lot of money be very focused very
careful and you're gonna do really great
I would love for you to finish this with
no additional debt